yesterday morning two bodies were found
buried in the back garden of the house
the more we run the more guilty we'll
see we just have sticks the plan
stakes the plan
it was a disturbing crime for 15 years
susan and christopher edwards the
seemingly normal couple covered up the
fact they'd murdered her parents baking
they were still alive they spent their
savings claimed pensions and took out
loans the more it unravels they realize
they're protecting each other all the
way through the story they've come up
with which is you know i was amazed when
i googled the real story to find out how
much of it is completely true and
actually the the truest bits are the
most bizarre bits
in total the couple stole more than a
quarter of a million pounds but in a
bizarre twist it emerged in court they'd
spent the vast majority on hollywood
memorabilia it is that delusional
obsession we see brought to life in the
drama
[Music]
we're taking these flights of fantasy
for a reason not just to be indulgent
but because it's we're kind of inside
the head of susan you know we find out
through the program uh faced abuse at
the hands of her father as a little girl
and
i think it's sort of her escapism
despite being the first time coleman has
got to work on a project with her
husband writer ed sinclair she had
primed some excuses should she hate the
script if it had been a script i would
have been really nervous but um i might
have said i'm not available i'm picking
the bubbles off my tights or something
but um
i was really excited when i first read
it it's just the originality in it and
the inventiveness
while susan and christopher edwards
remain in prison certainly christopher
says he's seen how he's portrayed in the
show's trailer i'm kind of
a little unnerved by that it must be
very strange and also because
you know susan's fantasy was the movies
and uh
and and here she is
represented in a tv series and she's on
the big screen so what will she
fantasize about now
[Music]
it is an absorbing way of bringing to
life the bizarre true story of a couple
who ran from reality until the truth
finally caught up with them katie
spencer sky news